we need to beat down those doors and
make sure that there's no extraneous
reason that somebody can't get into the
room that they deserve to be in Via
Merit equity
are you kidding me
Equity is just this horrible thing I
mean it's a trojan horse because it
sounds like equality
sounds like fairness it sounds like
against it right and the key point is
Equity needs to die
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic welcome
everybody to another episode of the into
the impossible podcast it's
approximately our 300th episode and who
better to share that with than our
friend
our most frequent guest Rock Contour
mathematician
dad
Eric Weinstein how are you my friend
great to be with you Brian we were
together last in person well earlier
today with uh Professor Daniel Green and
you can find that episode here or there
or somewhere uh in an episode called uh
what's what's going on with physical
what's wrong with physics we're not
going to talk about physics now we're
going to talk about the really important
stuff The Click bait the reason
everybody came here and that's really to
debrief from our last encounter in
person which was in a uh a very
disgusting place to spend some time in
the middle of fall and that was uh that
was Florence Italy I mean that was
horrible I don't know how we both
survived Florence Italy
and it was a arranged in honor of uh the
magnanimous and mellifluous uh David
berlinski you've known for quite some
time I've not known him for for as long
but I've come to enjoy him and like him
and and uh regard his intellect with
great respect and uh some trepidation
but there we encountered many many new
people at least from my perspective and
I use that to mine for guests on the
into the impossible podcast and three of
those guests have appeared so far and
that is Dr Jay bhattacharya of Stanford
University we spoke about uh disease
which is in a third year as we're
speaking almost exactly three years to
the day it's Valentine's Day by the way
Happy Valentine's Day Valentine's Day
yeah it's great to see you I got you a
gift I got you a gift uh Stuart zoom in
on this we have our we have our producer
here this is for you Eric my sweet
friend it's called foam sweet foam and
it is soap from Uranus and for Uranus
Uranus
okay Neil deGrasse Tyson uh he was not
there uh we had these esteemed
professors including Dr J not the
basketball player but Dr J bonacharya
has become a great friend and uh really
an intellectual hero and and an
incredible intellect who stood up
against the courage with courage against
the forces all right against him as he
described at that meeting
I also had on two interesting Christian
space scientists you know pause
scientists uh who have been on and
scientists who happen to be believing
Christians who are believing Christians
one of whom Dr James chore started off
Life as a Jew and he is what's known as
a Messianic Jew or a Jew for Jesus and
he I would say was one of my most
controversial episodes to date well I
received a quite a significant amount of
vitriol from about his appearance and
how could I platform him how could I
have a um a zealot and a science denier
even though this person has published
over 700 articles and he is a name chair
professor and a top research University
right
um and uh most of course that's a crazy
perspective yeah that's that's that's
really heterodox uh and a lot of the
comment came from uh in particular a
very well-known YouTuber who's going to
be on the podcast his name is Professor
Dave Farina he is calls himself a
professor he's uh not an official
Professor the way that Jim tour is or or
uh Luke Barnes who's the other guest
that I had on or Jay uh nevertheless he
makes Incredible content uh for his
channel but he's taken uh quite a a
strong approach to dealing with the
Christian space scientists that we were
encountering there including past guest
Stephen C Meyer and uh and people uh of
of that same stature Discovery Institute
folks that were there and it wasn't only
about that I'm getting the idea that I
don't have enough controversy in my life
we need to have more
um first thing I want to ask you is uh
regarding these these these gentlemen
um when we were there there was you were
the token uh atheist there I would say
you you described yourself as an atheist
I describe myself as a practicing
agnostic which we can get into the
distinction there but these gentlemen
two Jews who pray who aren't convinced
that it's to anyone up there and not
even convinced there's two of us right
um I forgot about your solipsism
but we talked about uh while you were
there you brought up um as a voice of
reason I would say you brought up this
notion that I've described in the
following kind of logical progression I
I was asked to write you know an
encomium for Stephen C Meyer's thousand
Page Long book he gave me a 10 10 day
deadline to do that thank you Stephen
um so I wasn't able to get it on the
back cover right so and this uh and and
this kind of logic that he and I discuss
is often phrased by me in the following
way uh there if there is a cause to the
universe if the universe came into being
there is a first cause and that first
cause then translates into a purpose a
meaning a reason perhaps for which the
universe was created perhaps there was a
subjugation of such an entity's Free
Will and there's no information in the
universe that doesn't Trace itself back
to some source and therefore Jesus and
the line of progression is is a short
one and yeah I don't associate that with
Stephen C Meyer yeah he associated with
I mean he agreed with me though he's
there for Jesus guy well there's a
personal God right so there's two
properties God must have right God must
have created the universe we're gonna
have a disagreement this is awesome all
right this is good this makes for good
television uh
the notion that you can have a universe
Without a Cause is sort of goes back to
Saint Thomas Aquinas and many other
thinkers uh unmoved movers and so forth
but eventually that cause has to have a
reason and that reason is ultimately the
Genesis of man and then their theology
Jesus is the reason uh for the for not
only the season but for the uh for the
creation itself in other words there has
to be a personal God and we Jews
practicing and you You observe Judaism
you're not practicing at the level I am
maybe or our mutual friend Ben Shapiro
might be but you you still have Shabbat
in the Shabbat prayers on a Friday
evening we say two two things we attest
to the fact by standing up holding a
glass of wine that God created the
universe and not only that that's a
universal literally Universal God but
also personally he led us out of Egypt
those are the two functions you're
talking about the Kiddush where the
first part before the wine
um is uh taken from Genesis or brishit
and and then the wine is drunk and it's
the separation between the first birth
and the second birth of the Jewish
people from the escape from its Rhymes
Egypt the narrow place that's right and
so if you were designing a religion
would you include physical laws or
physical forces and and would there be
is it necessary and sufficient to have a
creation of the universe as part of your
religion and a creation of a personal
relationship with God no
if you were God how would you have
orchestra how would you write the Torah
according to Eric Weinstein well I'm not
quite sure we have to figure out what it
is that we're asking and discussing I
think that these are very interesting
things because I think that the first
issue is uh effectively uh should
religious scientists live under a cloud
of Suspicion
and if their religion informs their
science what are we to make of that is
it contaminated and I think it's very
important to recognize that there are
multiple ways of being a scientist who
happens to be religious
um
and I've learned this over time so I've
been wrong on this topic and I've in
coming into contact with higher quality
scientists motivated by religion
I've come to understand that there's a
sub population that is very special and
interesting
and it's effectively a population of
people who agreed to the rules of
science they're not going to cheat on
the rules of science because Jesus
but they are going to use the idea of
purpose and a personal relationship with
God to give them courage to question
things that are essentially
unquestionable
within the union of scientists that will
get you thrown out of the Union of
scientists very quickly as to your point
so what we're talking about is we're
talking about relatively
self-destructive
scientists focused on science who get
their courage
from religion and some of their bearings
and their focus
so for example
um
many of these people do not believe that
there's a persuasive case for random
mutation as being the major engine
of selection
they believe that it is simply
improbable and they point to very often
the wistar Conference held at the
University of Pennsylvania at the Westar
Institute
um and they they try to say this is a
live issue where the books got closed
prematurely and in fact it's the
atheists according to them who were led
into error because they were trying to
close the books desperately so as not to
leave any Gap large enough uh for a God
to be smuggled into the Canon of science
I am persuaded that the Richard Dawkins
of the world who have contributed in my
estimation hugely to modern evolutionary
theory are so afraid of dealing with
religious colleagues that they were
eager to shut the books
and not give many of these people their
due
and what's more
um
the concept of intelligent design is a
really interesting one now my brother
who I think has just brilliant turns of
phrase and insights into evolutionary
theory one of his
you know Richard Dawkins I think wants
to be remembered for the meme not not as
the uh the the military the GIF that
gets sent over to Twitter that the meme
and the extended phenotype is his
greatest contributions and I think one
of Brett's
um better ideas is understanding
perception mediated selection
it is very clear that when you have
various breeds of dog they are
intelligently designed when you produce
a mule from a donkey and a horse that is
not a natural animal
you are producing an intelligently
designed animal when you create Orchid
varieties
so in all of these cases you have to
admit that darwinian theory has
perception-mediated selection the
display of bower Birds where they build
these structures and Adorn them with
blue in some cases
perception mediated selection is a form
of endogenous design which is
intelligent because it is mediated
through perception it's a good place to
study it because the words intelligent
design have been made radioactive right
and so what we're arguing about is
should the should the books have been
closed uh with the neo-darwinian
synthesis or should they have been left
open
and I have to say I really think that
without the religious scientists
who are willing to destroy themselves in
their careers but who still do not wish
their love of a benevolent God or a
fearsome Old Testament God or or a
personal Jesus Christ
I believe that many of those people are
responsible for prying the Books open
when Dawkins and Company wished to close
them prematurely and I'm honestly
sympathetic with the Dawkins perspective
I cannot stand what I've called Jesus
smuggling
where you're in some very careful
argument and you know you've set
everything up and then somebody sort of
says well I just believe that God's love
pervades everything you're saying Oh
Brother do I really have to listen to
this
um on the other hand
going toe-to-toe with some of these
religious scientists is an eye-opening
experience because they are highly
motivated not to God they know that
they're Heretics and if you think about
let's say
um Galileo's heresy
they are in some sense the Heretics of
today and their reputations are burned
at the stake they're not they're not
Bruno in
in the 1600s in the Square but I think
that what we have to say is
that many of these people are making
points that atheists wish would go away
what is the strongest or some give me a
couple of uh arguments from design that
appeal intellectually well I I'm
particularly motivated by two systems uh
in perception mediated selection one of
which has to do with the lamp basilis
muscle
which uh
produces a meaty lip that extends
outside of its shell in clearly the form
of a bait fish for bass and clear
streams
and when a bass swims by the muscle
Wiggles this little piece of meat that
is outside and it looks exactly like a
fish in the Stream
and the bass sometimes fall for it
sometimes see the ruse but if they fall
for it
the bass
clamps down on the lip and all of the
young of the muscle of the lampasillis
muscle
diffuse into the gills of the bass clamp
on to get a blood meal and are taken
away by the bass to distribute them in
the Stream where the muscle doesn't have
the ability to spread its young
there's no way you can tell me that that
isn't an intelligently designed system
and it's the bass that is the
intelligence
and the bass is specifically designing
its own fooling its own it's
self-deception because Dumber bass fell
for this trick before and smarter bass
uh didn't fall for it and that pushes
The Selective pressures in order to
produce this now there's a closely
related system that is not based on
predation which is the bass system but
is based on sexual reproduction and that
has to do with the ofrees system in
orchids so there's this one sort of
clade of orchids
um
where no I talk about this a lot Darwin
I asked the question one day what did
Darwin do after Origin of Species like
how do you follow yourself for Encore
and he wrote this book which I couldn't
believe the title which was on the
various contrivances by which British
and foreign orchids are fertilized by
insects and I thought that is the
dumbest thing I can possibly imagine but
Darwin being Darwin was incredibly smart
or orchids are incredibly speciated and
therefore they're a great system in
which to study various mechanisms now if
you read that Darwin does not understand
why the ofrey's Orchid
makes a replica of the species that
pollinate it
particularly the females with using its
lowest of five petals I believe and
producing incredible pheromones that are
almost indistinguishable from the
pheromones produced by a female who's
receptive to mating
and you watched Darwin trying to figure
out why this would be and he can't
figure out that this is actually a
consequence of his own Theory because
the theory is too new and it's just like
one of the most beautiful vignettes and
nobody talks about it and so what I
would say is
in that situation a male does tries to
copulate with the flower not realizing
that it's not a female and if it's
fooled twice then the flowers don't have
to give up an expense an energetically
expensive nectar meal
and they can they can be very cheap
about it all they have to do is to offer
an erzot's sexual experience and this is
called pseudocopulation so in both of
these systems
if you look at the mirror Orchid for
example it's a stunning replica with
hair and the shininess on the back and
this whole the whole thing you can tell
what is fooling the pollinator now both
of these are systems in which that which
is dumber is fooling that which is
smarter using the intelligence the
bounded intelligence of the thing being
fooled to intelligently design a trap
and both of these are effectively
parasites because they're stealing
energy
from the dupe and that energy is used to
further the species in an antagonistic
fashion
um
if I make that point and I say actually
intelligent design is all through the
animal kingdom it's just not what you
think it's not a question of an initial
Creator who's deciding you know then
move mood or saying you're an aardvark
you're a eucalyptus tree
so endogenous intelligent design is
essential to darwinian Theory within
Brett's context of perception-mediated
selection
and then what do you get from the uh
atheistic science communities like we
will have no such discussion because
what they want is a very clean bright
line
you know show me the card carrying
members of the church
and we will dispatch them and my feeling
is
that's not how the games play
I love that you worked in sexual
selection on Valentine's Day uh it is
don't try this at home
uh so I mean I guess yeah pivoting to
where the information comes into play
has been my challenge
um it's not altogether
more impressive to me if you invoke a
deity you know at the last second or if
you have to invoke it at the beginning
of time whatever that means but I think
that there is you know kind of an
um almost un you know
difficult to engage in a reproach mom
between these two different fields and I
wonder why it is and from my perspective
as somebody who's agnostic which and I
do make a distinction I I ask this the
first podcast guest on the into the
impossible podcast was not Eric it was
Freeman Dyson and Freeman I'm honored to
have been bumped
uh that's not what he said at the time
no the uh the claim that Freeman would
make is that he was agnostic and I said
Freeman that's very interesting you know
uh just out of curiosity what church do
you go to
oh I don't go to church okay uh well um
how would a very intelligent alien
looking down at the Earth and seeing you
and your you know fellow Countryman
Richard Dawkins how would this
intelligent alien distinguish between
the two of you if your practices are
identical in other words you don't go to
the same church that Richard Dawkins
doesn't go to so by what means you
distinguish yourself as agnostic from
just atheist and just a lazy atheist or
or just a maybe a I don't mean dishonest
I'm not going to besmirch him sure I
loved him but but the point being that
you're not being fully honest with you
you're really an atheist but you don't
want to say it for whatever reason you
don't want to say it
um so why not come out with it and I
think the thing that distinguishes the
Believers that we met there that I met
there about acharya Luke Barnes and uh
to a very are they all out are they all
all these episodes are out yes no no out
of the closet yeah you mean as Believers
I'm telling you oh yes there's a huge
stigma against being a Believer oh no no
James tour not only has yeah but I don't
know I didn't know Jay's status oh yes
yes no Jay is Jay is uh we talked about
it extensively in our interview and and
actually we'll pivot to that towards the
end we talk about um you know the the
current status of kovid and the the
prospects for what we call teshuva
repentance is it possible for the the
proponents of lockdowns and masking and
also we should also just say that given
that Jay's last name is evidently
Bengali
um he is a Christian uh believing yes uh
academic very very devout and we spoke
about the role the church played not
only in his life you know from for a
very long time in his guiding principle
in Morality and also in the role that he
played with the covid-19 uh information
yeah standing up at his church and and
engaging his church and and fellow
church members to engage them to provide
some of the first samples for the study
that led to eventually the Great
Barrington declaration anyway not
talking about him I really want to talk
about people like
uh James tour so I feel like as a
Believer or as a agnostic you can doubt
your uh belief at any time theodicy it's
a classic question a lot of good things
happen to that by the way which is more
annoying to you when something good
happens to a bad person or something bad
happens to a good person
um it's not even a context if some good
thing happens to a bad person I always
hope that it might give them pause and
that gives them an opportunity to course
correct okay fine so theodicy is a
classic thing that Believers have to
struggle with and you know some will say
well you know that that's our only thing
that we thought I'm not gonna get uh you
know comment either way but I asked
James tour let me just stick to James
Stewart and it's on camera I said look
James uh I have doubts you know like do
you ever doubt your theism uh do you
ever have this notion and I found it
very striking because he said absolutely
not he said he'd never Downs for one
nanosecond I don't believe that I I find
it hard to believe it but I also found
it in concert with his conversion to
Christianity
in Judaism as you know our catechism is
is the Shema which means you are
commanded to love God and what does it
mean do you have to be commanded to love
your your children I don't I don't feel
like you have to be it's natural to love
your kids right you only command
something that's unnatural right don't
eat pork it works pretty delicious I
used to eat it in my my youth uh it's
pretty good so don't eat it you know
don't shoot it with melon that really
gets you oh that was tough in Italy I
had to skip over the lobster
um but you don't command something
that's easy to do in other words God is
Not lovable in Judaism God is not
considered lovable he's actually
considered fearful and awesome in a
quasi mixed
that's the New Testament no I did read
the sequel uh so now tell me do you ever
doubt your atheism and what do you mean
the time right okay so so that would be
great yeah so what makes you doubt oh
just uh
imagine just believing all the time with
100 confidence that the world has no
purpose it's a giant uh pointless yeah
pointless exercise sounded Furious
signifying nothing uh it's really Bleak
and I don't think we're meant
to be atheists I think we're meant to be
religious and I think that there's a
Chomsky and programmer of religion and
so
if you don't honor that
you're going to end up oscillating your
whole life because you're gonna
believe in nothing
and then you're going to find out that
life can't be supported so easily by
believing in nothing and then you're
gonna overdo it and so rather than being
a spring
awaiting a spring engaging in simple
harmonic oscillation between atheism and
belief I thought I'd skip the round trip
and try both camping and decamping
so that there's less oscillation and
that's and you know I think prayer is
incredibly important and if you try to
Chisel on Prayer by saying I know this
is not true but I'm going to do it
anyway I don't think it's very effective
yeah so
you know I go to movies that I don't
believe actually happened I don't think
Star Wars is a documentary and although
the Matrix is and
um
I think that in the same way you have to
be immersed in part
uh in religion
so that it doesn't come and bite you and
by the way Jim is a very special case
and I I hope that I'm not saying
anything out of turn
Jim's introduction to Christianity was
that they just seemed happier
he found a group of Christians who
immediately put him in a good mood made
him feel wanted loved care about it was
the experience it hadn't had
and that's a very different issue than
Nano machines
uh providing a puzzle to him that he
can't solve and so if you ask the
question of why does he not doubt
himself
I believe that what he came into
Christianity for is different than what
gives him confidence because I believe
that he has a scientist's confidence
whether he's accurate or not is a
different question well there I think I
might disagree because in the
conversation that we had on on the on
the podcast he was expressing it as a
result of direct Revelation that he had
encountered Jesus Christ uh whether
through prayer meditation we have
different conversations and I'll I'll
leave it to Jim to sort that out but I
do know fair enough that one of his
points no no it's true uh you want to
have a bad a bad you know like join a
religion where everyone's unhappy and
miserable or or stay in the religion and
from birth as he was Judaism is a tough
religion it's a lot harder than some
others yeah and
I believe in a certain sense uh
Christianity softens the strictures and
and difficulties of Judaism some of the
abstractions you make certain things
very concrete yeah
um but I think you know I want to get
back to the science I think Jim's basic
point is that Nano machines that we find
in nature to sell or like ATP synthase
for example you know inside of
mitochondria
it's one of I think only two wheels that
we know about in nature the other being
flagella
um of rotors yeah and
I think his point of view is you have no
idea how difficult these machines are to
make that if you took the best chemists
you give them the largest budgets and
you let them run for tens of thousands
of years there's nothing we're doing now
souped up that would get you to these
machines yeah and that's where he gets a
lot of pushback from from others and
like a lot of the gaps perspective I'm
just saying that I believe that some of
his confidence isn't from the fact that
that is true or isn't true but he has
looked at the situation and he has come
to that determination and his feeling
about this is if you want to talk about
uh minimal explanations his belief is
it's easier to deal with a conscious
designer I don't share that
but I understand his perspective
so uh pivoting to something that's still
in the news but wait a second I want to
get back to Jay beticherry oh yeah okay
we all benefited
from Jay's Devotion to Christianity
because it gave him the stupid courage
to do the right thing even though we Now
understand that fauci and Collins were
having this little back Channel about
Swift and devastating takedowns of the
reasons Fringe epidemiologists and you
know my feeling is is that we just need
to get rid of the Collins and fauces
because we can't afford them inside of
the Temple of science if you're going to
be reasonable and reasoned and you're
going to be in charge of this you cannot
engage in anti-collegal Behavior like
that it's more than just anthek
collegial I mean it's it's it's
almost borderline you know
right so that actually I did want to
continue talking about God and therefore
Tony fauci sorry
um that joke does it Tony found she's
got you missed that
um completely so when when I was
thinking about this episode and what we
could call it you know I want to call it
um
what happens below the Von Carmen line
stays below the Ron Carmen line so the
very common line is 100 kilometers or so
it's a fictitious surface over which we
consider space to begin the atmosphere
to sort of end
and there are three main actually Four
events that are taking place right now
in the sub Von Carmen zone region of our
atmosphere uh one of those is global
warming another one is uh covid-19 which
is respiratorily passed as we know uh
and the other one uh is
um uh nuclear Annihilation yeah and
actually there's a fourth one which has
come to light very recently which are
UFOs and unidentified flying objects
operating in the troposphere and
possibly being and being shot down all
the time uh lately as of uh this this
recording on February 14th
um so there's four phenomena these are
really you know highlighting and
actually another thing that happened on
Valentine's Day in 1990 was uh the
famous pale blue dot image taken by the
Voyager 1 spacecraft at the command of
finger puppet extraordinaire somewhere
over there is Carl Sagan so we commanded
it turn around take a picture and he
called it famously a mode of dust sir
suspended on a Sunbeam and how many
people he waxed and poetically have
fought over their fraction of that one
pixel in that famous image uh suspended
on a Sunbeam when I ask you of these
different phenomena UFOs covid global
warming and nuclear Annihilation which
one is keeping you up at night the most
or all of them the most no I mean look
they're equal well
as you know some n years ago uh I
started speaking about the twin nuclei
problem which is that when we
uh in 1953 uh entered the nucleus of
eukaryotic cell and extracted the
three-dimensional structure of DNA
we became Godlike within that nucleus
and then less than six months earlier in
1952 with the explosion the test of IV
Mike
uh we came to know the physicists
brought sin and came to know the power
of the Sun in the form of thermonuclear
reactions mediated by the tellerulom
design
and my feeling is
um
it's interesting when you tell people
you need to worry about the twin nuclei
problem and then covet happens coming
you know next door to a
a lab with a very active charity called
the Eco Health Alliance led by Peter
dajik defended by was it 66 or 69 Nobel
laureates in the Lancet I'm just
complete Corruption of scientific norms
um so let's assume for the moment that
uh this is some sort of biological
weapons convention work around
um that may have spilled over through a
wet Market or something like that
and then we're in Ukraine and we're not
allowed uh to question why we are
going to higher and higher levels of
escalation now I don't know about you
but almost all of my ancestors came from
Ukraine and
if you ask Jews Ashkenazi Jews about
where they came from in that region they
used to they usually say something like
well it's a little region that sometimes
is Poland and sometimes it was
Lithuanian sometimes it was Ukraine and
sometimes it was Russian sometimes the
Belarus
we cannot afford to have these borders
oscillate as they have always oscillated
in fact they didn't oscillate if you
look at a time lapse much after World
War II up until the fall of the Berlin
wall because of the Specter of nuclear
Annihilation and I will point out that
teller famously came from the I think
the Lutheran gymnasium in Budapest with
the Laszlo rats this is high school math
teacher
and uh and with zillers and Von Neumann
and like the world's greatest Secondary
High School the world's greatest High
School JV team give it up for the
Lutheran juveniles and then
um Stan ulam came from a town which I'm
now forced to call leviv
which I think I always grew up saying
something closer to levov and
that is a Polish town in eastern like
Northeastern Ukraine where we're
fighting ukrainians are fighting like
eight seconds by Hypersonic missile to
the Border in Poland
so I'm not supposed to say I called it
but we're insane I mean just the swing
nuclei problem within the space of the
time that I was talking about it
we're facing potential
absolute cataclysms
and you know we're now funding more Eco
Health Alliance we're we're trying to
figure out if we should be sending
planes after sending tanks
into Ukraine we're not supposed to
discuss it nobody knows what's going on
um
I don't know what we're doing but I do
know that we're playing Russian roulette
and we're not going to be surviving this
if we keep playing this every time
somebody wants to change a border in
Central and Eastern Europe and just you
know lingering on that one one moment
longer thinking about in our community
in the Jewish Community every single
Jewish community in San Diego Los
Angeles Washington DC there is some
tribute to the Holocaust or you know
there's some Memorial to the Holocaust
uh bigger one smaller ones you know
Washington DC and LA are two notable
ones and then of course in Israel vashem
um
I I was thinking of you know kind of
getting your take on it we don't have we
have one Hiroshima and there's one
Nagasaki and there's those are the two
plan there's there's places I mean here
in San Diego we actually have a Peace
Garden and then in Japanese but there's
nothing as visceral as uh if you've been
to any of these Holocaust Memorial I've
only been to yard Basham actually I
should come to see him is powerful but
it's not I wouldn't put it in my top
five yeah so I so that's a Lacuna in my
uh Jewish Journey but but at any rate
why aren't why don't we kind of
stigmatize not about the morality I
think it was ultimately moral and it was
a good decision by Truman but but
ultimately
if we had more awareness you've called
for with with deadly seriousness the
resumption of tests nobody listens the
resumptions of above ground rare rare
and controlled and and moderate but to
to bring to a visceral sense the notion
of what we're playing with literal
atomic fire
um what about stepping back from that
with the inherent difficulties of a you
know teller device and the result in
radioactivity that that might accompany
it I would have come in but what about
this notion of well we are not doing
enough in the never forget realm when it
comes to nuclear Annihilation or just
Devastation not I don't think the world
the world will go on just fine I mean
there'll be a planet here but whole life
and sorry when you say that
there will be a sphere here
there will be like cockroaches and uh
Target grades see I know where you're
going because yeah
um but tell me what what could we do to
and then obviously my follow-up question
is gonna be was there an analog for
covet I've changed my mind about this uh
uh I called it about as cleanly as
somebody can call it and then it
happened and then we denied that it was
coming out of the wuwan Institute of
virology
and we're also denying that we are
trying to Corner a conventional
enemy who also possesses unconventional
weapons which
pardon my French but this is just the
dumbest thing I can imagine all the same
people who said that Putin would never
invade Ukraine uh are right here telling
us exactly why this is safe which it
isn't
we are This is the End we're on borrowed
time
and we're not going to avoid this we
don't have the right leaders
you know this just doesn't make any
sense and the reason it doesn't make any
sense
is because people need to be so
proximate to the problem that it plays
on their mind and they can't think about
anything else and
the two monuments that I would recommend
above all others to uh those lost in the
Holocaust
or maybe three
okay so the Berlin
Memorial I can't even explain it
you know it's basically these Stones
these pillars and they start off very
shallow you could have a picnic on one
and you wander into this thing
and the height just gets higher and
higher and higher and it's mind-numbing
and you lose all perspective as to where
you are and you start to realize what
happens when life is devalued and
degraded
and all you see is the coldest deer
Stones it is
who thought it reminds me of Bohemian
Rhapsody it made sense to Freddie
Mercury to write this thing but if you
describe it let's write a really long
song that mimics several operas that
makes no sense uh I would never have
greenlit this project because I'm an
idiot right the next one is Bobby Yar uh
go to Kiev and try to keep yourself from
feeling
sickness of standing near this ditch
where people were just machine gunned
and executed
it's a visceral thing that will cause
you to lose your [__]
and I guess the last one that really
matters to me
which isn't even about Jews is uh
there's an amazing sculpture of a boxing
ring on an angle
and it's to the cinti which is sort of a
Aroma Community uh boxing Legend named
Johannes trollman
who
was very popular in German circles as a
great boxing Legend he sort of was using
the Muhammad Ali technique and being
highly athletic rather than just large
and Powerful
and he was very good looking
swarthy complexion and he fought in
Germany
and the Nazis took his you know there
was a decision against him
and the crowd was having none of it
because they knew boxing so
the Germans the Nazis uh were faced with
the idea that this was not going down
and so they said okay we're going to
change the rules to neutralize this
guy's Style
so he divorces his wife to save her life
I mean I'm just it's hard not to get
emotional about this
he covers himself his dark skin with
flower to mock the Aryan preoccupation
with purity
and he loses
and this guy gets sent to a camp and
they're using him to train other people
and put on exhibitions and finally they
can't take it anymore and I think that
they just forget whether he got a hoe in
the back of his head or a single bullet
but it took us until recently to
reinstate his boxing championship that
was taken away from him
I'd go to those three memorials see how
you do
well that was unexpected but but very uh
but extremely meaningful I think but
yeah but my point is it won't last
that that it'll wear off yeah the human
the treadmill I've never had a
near-death experience for like two weeks
yeah every cup of water is it you know
when Warren Zevon was dying
I think David Letterman asked him what
you know is there any message in this
you know that you're about to die you've
had this incredible uh
Canon of songs that you've written and
performed is there any lesson and
Warren's even said enjoy every sandwich
and you know sandwich is a funny word
and it says deadly serious point which
is you don't appreciate
just the sheer Joy Of Being Alive
because you can't there's no way to keep
these lessons in mind we're not going to
explode it above I mean it's the smart
thing to do but everyone's going to say
well you're going to contaminate the
atmosphere it's like you know what
you're going to do you're going to say
Slava Ukraine
and you're going to post it and then
you're gonna get on to the next thing
and you're not going to think about it
and you're gonna and then one day maybe
has nothing to do with this incident but
eventually a much more deadly virus is
going to come through the atmosphere and
eventually there's going to be a nuclear
exchange which you can't handle
and you're going to say why why didn't
we listen to the
you know it reminds me of in New Orleans
when Katrina hit
and the Levee broke
and I remember somebody on TV saying who
could possibly imagine
that the levy would break and I thought
didn't Led Zeppelin sing a song called
what they do yeah I mean it's just I
don't understand it but I've come to
accept that most humans cannot live with
abstract knowledge if something hasn't
happened in 20 years it's not it's not
going to happen if it's never happened
then you never need to worry about
anything that's a low probability
doesn't need to be thought about in the
context of excitement I think you're
exactly right and I think I've seen this
in Turkey by the way we've had a huge
devastating earthquake and erdogan was
celebrating the fact that by relaxing
building standards he got much more
housing right and where everything right
and I think that's actually pertinent
too we're not going to talk much about
UFOs and physics but just UFOs and
phenomena
I kind of feel like that's what's going
on right now I think we have these
balloons we have these the uh unmanned
air and I called it you know uh bread
and saucers and it's something that you
can kind of like appreciate like the
song by uh Miley Cyrus is going around
now it's called flowers and she's an
amazing voice and she has incredible
characteristics but it's a song that I
could sing about it I've become a huge
Ariana Grande oh really that gal she's
about pipes she has oh my God is she a
great singer so I did not I did not I
did not get that the first time yeah so
but and with Miley trust me she's got
incredible range and she's musical she
understood now Eric you know me um you
were playing piano earlier today uh you
know my only instrument is Spotify right
that's about all I can play and I don't
play it well I can sing the song Flowers
by Miley Cyrus it's got you know a one
Hertz you know kind of bandwidth it's
very small kind of range or you know so
how does it go
um it goes uh I can buy myself flowers I
can hold my own and it's written like
about her ex-husband now they just got
the war then it's all in People magazine
which I know you subscribed to a
physical review letters
near you I was actually in People
magazine last year most record quoted as
handsome as sexiest man I don't know in
this office no for uh a solar phenomenon
a solar physics fanata
um now Miley when she sings that song
it's it's you know like I said it's it's
one millhertz fraction of her octave
range right
um but I can sing it so it's something I
can appreciate I can replicate it I can
do a tick tock of it and so forth it's
easy
Dr Brian Keating on all platforms
but saucers it's something people can
explore are these balloons people can
understand a balloon maybe they're all
this maybe everything that's happened so
far has been this and maybe now we can
dismiss it or maybe we could say it's a
military thing and so is it in other
words it's sort of the same thing in
that it's approachable it's relatable
it's you don't require Advanced quantum
physics to understand it
um first of all what do you make of
these things and is it potentially at
its core a giant psyop designed to
distract us like the bread and circus is
that bread and saucers look
the thing is
there are two basic doors into the this
phenomenon one of is indirect evidence
and the other is direct evidence
if you ask me if you go by direct
evidence
um with everybody owning a camera in
their pocket
uh you have to say that this is nonsense
because there is no direct evidence
that's high quality there's no high
quality data in the public domain that's
right so let's just say that from the
direct evidence perspective this is
nonsense it doesn't exist it's very
silly
okay now you switch your lens
you say there seems to be an
overwhelming amount of indirect evidence
like psychotically overwhelming and I
was unprepared for this until I started
looking at it I have no idea how we I
mean you can get rid of people who see
ghosts and people who have a need for
attention and you're left with people
who don't want to talk about it whose
lives have been destroyed and
you know particularly some very kind of
modest and modest cognitive gift folks
who seem to be able to act at the level
of Brando which I don't believe
I believe that these people have been
hurt
um some of them with by who with
necrosis we don't know
um but according to Gary Nolan he's seen
damage paths through tissue that
correspond to crazy stories where the
story actually has a physical Trace
um I would say from the indirect
perspective I don't think that we're
capable
of
faking this at this level
even if we wanted to even if we wanted
to fly you know SR-71 blackbirds and
their successors and we wanted a story
so in case anybody sees one
you know the jig isn't up so I've never
seen a subject that has that profile
zero direct evidence overwhelming and
direct evidence
somebody smarter than me has to call it
and in terms of probability and amazing
sense between getting hearings on the
ecohealth alliance versus getting Public
Access
no why do we have a government like I
mean I think a lot of this flows down
from government not all but a lot of it
does
sources and methods has become the bane
of our Democratic existence I'm
convinced that there is an issue of
privilege around many of the things we
cannot resolve you cannot have this many
things
shoved into sources and methods so that
the public can never figure out what's
going on and classified and put into a
garage sources and methods and we have
this you know we have an incredibly
incredible structure for avoiding the
Freedom of Information Act
where we have private companies the
private companies are entrusted with
secrets that you can't afford to hold in
government
so in the same way that you know a rich
person will set up an irrevocable trust
and said what assets I don't have the
assets penetrate this right you know and
the answer is the person doesn't have
the assets a container has the assets
and that somebody is in control of the
container directing the container to
make loans which are you know taxed
under different structures and uh so the
person is unlimited liability living an
incredible lavish lifestyle with no
assets and so my feeling is that the
government has figured out the foia
issue which is like what information we
don't have any information but it seems
to me if you know if there were
hyper-intelligent aliens or something
huge
um you know kind of malevolent entity on
Earth that they couldn't find a better
way to destroy Earth than than sort of
undermining our faith in science and I
feel like we're doing that ourselves
the cowards in science are doing that in
particular you know a short time ago
uh I was against public health and
people thought like
how can you make it what is that I want
to explain what you mean Public Health
not
just funding for you know we have a a
culture of non-scientific behavior that
involves manipulating massive numbers of
people
um
because both War
and pandemic
are two places where you cannot make a
Libertarian argument you can't say well
whoever wants to go can go you know good
luck with that then you it's going to be
a self-estinguishing argument
so there is a sort of sacred obligation
when invoking Public Health saying you
all have to do the following thing right
and unfortunately this
this appeals to people who have who are
willing to forego income for the
privilege of telling other people how to
live their lives so it selects for the
wrong element
ideally what you would want is people
who are loathed to tell other people how
to live their lives who only invoke this
when it is absolutely necessary but good
luck convincing
uh people who are you know two clicks
away from Pure libertarianism to go into
this public health field so we
absolutely need Public Health
but we can't afford
fouchy style Colin style public health
and you know what that is and dashics
you know and and it's the manipulation
of people invoking science
to tell people to do things that you
claim are in the best interest the
social welfare function of your of your
nation
it is destroyed
our credibility because people do not
distinguish between science and public
health like medicine and public
Physicians and okay so it's time to
recognize that we need a divorce
we've been separated for a long time and
we forgot to cancel the care the credit
card and public health has been running
around charging everything
to the AmEx
uh that belongs to science and now we
have this huge bill it's like well what
about science what about all those Nobel
Prize winners it's like you know what
you're absolutely right
Public Health needs to pay for itself
out of its own budget its own
credibility budget it needs to leave
science alone and we need to cut Tony
fauci and Francis Collins loose
and you know Jay obviously had you know
utmost respect for the scientific
accomplishments of Collins and he even
said he studied from a textbook written
by fauci back in the 80s when he was a
med student wait wait a second Jay says
if I understand him correctly
I worked for 35 years in the belly of
the Beast having no idea how a
university actually operates
that's a much more important statement
in my estimation the true point is
he first of all he's not only a
physician he's also an economist right
MD PhD and right and Stanford for both
right
he he lived his entire life in Stanford
not realizing that there's a secret book
that you pull out in a panic room where
the bookcase swings open it's like
here's how the actual stuff goes down
and this is what I discovered at Harvard
and it's shocking because you don't
realize the way power and science
interact in these institutions
hasn't gotten worse I mean I'm just I'm
gonna quote some statistics that I like
Stanford speaking of Stanford only
institution I was ever fired from not
that I'm bitter about that uh Stanford
recently enrolled 16 937 undergraduate
and graduate students and concurrently
list 15 750 administrative staff nearly
one to one in the past as such costly
praetorian bloat I forgot where I got
this maybe Heather McDonald I have to
look up the source for this would have
sparked a faculty to Heather McDonald
but not now
uh six figure salary diversity Equity
inclusion commissary that's why I think
it's Heather because she wrote this
wonderful book The diversity delusion
which has a whole page dedicated to UCSD
by the way
um consequently uh problematic
standardized tests are damned as biased
and antithetical to diversity yeah we
have to destroy the structure
what replaces it so you you overthrow uh
Putin and then who do you put in there
why make something that works worse
why make it that you're stipulating its
work it's not working though you're
saying Academia the research University
yeah or I mean there's just a university
like we don't have a university and then
there's University part two where you
really I don't know we have we have
something called the AAU the association
of American universities and we had
something that used to be called
what Nas slug but I forget what it's
been renamed to which is the National
Association of land-grant colleges okay
and these were the prestige research
powerhouses as distinguished from the
also Rands
the degradation in this class of
university is so profound
do
to
deciding that we are going to empower
Administration over the professor to run
these things
every University that you want to be
associated with The Prestige comes from
the professors having both a culture and
being in charge
I was speaking to a colleague of ours
who will remain nameless
um
and this person said to me not knowing
that I'd studied this issue with the
National Bureau for economic research
and the Harvard economics department and
the Sloan labor in Immigration programs
Eric you have to understand what a
Provost is the Provost is my boss
I said stop right there
I said the Provost is not your boss you
don't have a boss you are your boss if a
Provost is your boss you have to not be
at that University
[Music]
you don't have a boss the whole thing
goes out the window
and I started hearing about a secondary
Dean who is under the president not
under the control of the Provost who's
sort of the academic administrator
and this is a Dean for diversity equity
and inclusion now I love diversity as
you know you can tell from my personal
life and I
you know friends family it's it's pretty
much the United Nations that's what no
I'm just saying
I I love languages I love food I love
travel so that's that's an easy one
um
it's not the inclusion people who
deserve to be in the room we need to
beat down those doors and make sure that
there's no extraneous reason that
somebody can't get into the room that
they deserve to be in Via Merit equity
are you kidding me
Equity is just this horrible thing I
mean it's a trojan horse because it
sounds like equality
sounds like fairness it sounds like
against it right and the key point is
Equity needs to die
I'm looking for my diversity Equity
inclusion award which is around here
somewhere congratulations yes
um but all the professors who are any
good you know call me up and tell me I
can't stand it should I retire should I
leave should I stop it is a crisis I
mean there is a crisis in the academic
you know kind of um just Amelia that we
do have this first of all yes that the
most powerful administrators used to be
Provost Dean's academic Affairs now it
is has moved to a diversity Equity
anybody focused
we should just ask a question do you
believe in equity inside of an academic
context that's considered the Third Leg
of the three-legged stool by the
president please don't do the Devil's
Advocate this is an incredible
pervasive it is look
this gives communism a bad name
what is the motto of Communism if you
had to sum up communism in one effort
from each according to his knee means to
each according to his needs from each
according to his abilities
right to each according to his or her
needs right
okay this is not even communism
this is saying the more able person may
need to be struck down so that the less
able person
can perform
so that we achieve this outcome
and
I'm sorry you know Marxism is bad enough
uh and I'm not talking about a social
net a social safety net I'm not talking
about here at this universe I'm not
talking about even socialism I'm talking
about this is you know Dr Seuss theater
Geisel who has a library named after him
wrote an obscure book called on Beyond
zebra which I believe is now banned I'm
not sure if you have a copy it's worth
it I do I know
um this is on Beyond communism
so it's like this is communism for
people who didn't think the amount of
suffering under communism was sufficient
you know true Equity has never been
tried even vaguely the Soviet Union
would have been freaked out to try
equity
um you know the old saying as to why
Stalin uh maintained freedom for his
theoretical physicists was well he was
crazy but he wasn't stupid this is just
dumb and we need to get rid
of the e in die
when and and certainly I think there's
there's underground You Know spoken
about in hush Whispers uh because of the
fact that we recognize that in the past
it was more than necessary and it may
have over corrected at this very
University you and I have talked about
this before we had both Jonas Salk the
Salk Institute it was forbidden to own
land here my house title it says I can't
sell it to a Jew uh Hispanic or a
Mexican or a Native American
um so that's kind of funny that a Jew
owns this house uh and uh you're Jewish
too Jewish
um and uh Maria Gephart mayor could
could only come here and have our
physics department named after her uh
because uh you know she was kicked out
of uh Chicago she couldn't get a
permanent position in Argonne
um so certainly it was necessary and I
think what was necessary Equity was
never necessary not Equity but but to
have to have uh I would just say
affirmative action at that point to let
in people who were married to crowd they
were they deserve to be here I don't
think you could argue Jonas Salk and
Maria didn't earn a position I don't
know what conversation we're having I
just said that we need inclusion of
people who have the Merit to be in there
we have to be a visual and we have to
realize that those people are going to
come in every flavor okay all 31 Flavors
according to Baskin Robbins fine
yeah no
no equity is Over My Dead Body
so
and by the way exclusion needs to be
practiced people who believe in equity
need to be excluded from a meritocratic
uh context because you can't afford you
know we I think we saw this in Algeria
where you have an election and the
electorate decides to get rid of
democracy well yeah Hitler was voted
democratically I know so you have to
have safeguards
that say
um look we have a long-term commitment
and the threshold for undoing Merit has
to be extraordinary and it's nowhere
close to being met in fact
you know my slogan is uh
uh and bigotry and online Anonymous
chess
well now they've done that with
Anonymous auditions for for uh most
classical orchestras
um I want to Pivot to a less uh less
controversial so that's not a
controversial subject I'm sorry no I'm
joking because I'm going to go but it's
not controversial I want to say to you
that I don't believe that this is a
controversy I believe what happened is
that we lost control of a layer that
became possessed of cult-like beliefs
and so when you're talking about like
the heavens Gate cult I'm sure that I
believe many things that the heavens
gate people would find controversial but
they're not here right now
right right because they're this is a
self-estinguishing behavior we're not
going to do a self-extinguishing
behavior we are got we have got to
figure out how to get rid of all of this
infrastructure that we cooked ourselves
up on over the last five years but maybe
it's not possible within the current
structure are you familiar with
something called the Ikea effect yeah
the Ikea effect
maybe you're saying that the uh
people feel differently as to whether
they've built something and have put
Sweat Equity into something as to
whether it's handed to them they ascribe
more value to something that they've
created right so this is something
they've created right so that you are
familiar with it so they've created this
structure and these structures and it's
not
if I want to Pivot away from this but to
this and I want to say the following
this the university system is has now
ingested this Phenom these these you
know divisions of diversity Equity
inclusion Vice Chancellor there's an
apparatus there's a structure it's
detailed we're not the first person
people to talk about it we already
referred to Heather McDonald you can go
there to see it what about if the secret
and all these things are coming
Downstream from Academia in other words
the political class the the infighting
the lack of fear over Ukraine right okay
so I want to Pivot to this is that
brings up my next topic maybe we need a
different model for the Academia for
Academia maybe we need maybe the the
non-profit or the uh or the you know
kind of Scholastic for its own sake
approach is no longer relevant in the
21st century after all it's a thousand
years old I'd want to do this so what
what you don't think that there's an
opportunity to replace they went crazy
okay so we have this like Red Guard
Red Guard took over I'm not going to
pretend hey forget about that then does
it say is Academia in need and went
overhaul I mean we've detailed already I
don't think I don't think you're
understanding where I am
we can't build a container that can hold
money and funds that isn't susceptible
to this so right now this is a container
of water okay
imagine that the sides of this container
were coated with poison and every time
that you had water you wanted to put in
you're thinking about the water but
you're not thinking about the container
which poisons everything
so what you are allowed to do and not
allowed to do I mean I'm all
I understand if you want to get rid of
Legacy preferences if you want to get
rid of sports preferences if you want to
tax the university endowments I mean
there's a million whatever there's
millions of things but we cannot have a
world where the only containers that you
can build all inherit the same problem
why did everything go crazy
if you've ever seen an ant Mill
um
you have a bunch of ants that are
leaving some sort of ascent Trail and
they go around in a circle because all
they're doing is following the trail and
the trail has happened you know
right and so in that circumstance
you've created an ant Mill where every
container produces the same effect so
what am I supposed to do I'm supposed to
come up with a you know
um
Harvard is supposed to open a campus in
Riyadh because it doesn't have the same
laws this is ridiculous
this is our country we're being idiotic
uh nobody is clamoring for uh
you know hired Jewish participation in
the NBA
um what we need to do is we need to make
sure that we are fair
and we need to help people who I I no
longer am going to say underrepresented
groups
because in fact that questions well
who's over represented and the answer is
I'm sorry you know if if Sophie's choice
if Japanese Americans you know are
absolutely the best at algebraic
topology or algebraic geometry
um so be it so be it
and you know if the question is well
what about certain groups that have been
historically disadvantaged it's like how
do we get them some advantages early in
their career so that we're not messing
around with Merit at the ends of their
career so we just need we need we need
to end Equity period the end
uh given that I think that you know the
motor homunculus of society and culture
that the
Academia really is the you know the root
cortex of of almost everything in
society right I mean look at Twitter
well look at Twitter okay so there's so
Twitter they're journalist and they were
the apex predators on on Twitter they
had the most prestige yeah these little
blue check marks Etc uh they all went to
journalism school okay
all went to college right so look at how
much in our culture and these ideas and
I mean I have a blue check mark and it's
not some big deal you may or may not be
uh you may or may not be important
notable yes that's right there I think
you're notable
um but the question I have is is really
um you know well if if Academia plays
such a huge role and to say that it
hasn't I mean you have this famous quote
uh you know if you were teleported back
to the 1950s or from the 1950s into a
living room today uh the biggest thing
that you would notice are I say 73 73.
you'd notice flattered the TVs are a
little bit flatter and they can't find
the victory subtract the screens and
more or less it's only stylistic
differences okay so I'll do you uh 38 or
10 centuries more go back to the year
1080 in the University of bologna and in
Italy and there was a guy and he was
scraping on a piece of Rock with another
piece of rock and there were a bunch of
young people sitting in front of him
um now that hasn't changed right so if
you teleport in here they'd say wow the
walls sure are flat you know it's a
similar kind of thing we're not in a
cave anymore uh so why not say that
actually the whole thing needs to be
rethought remade in a way to serve the
needs of the you know the third
millennium since this was was these
things are elitist institution of course
no no you say of course
they're supposed to be elite
institutions will you you and I buy into
it okay so with ivy league educated
right we both put out some freemium on
on such things right
it has nothing to do with the ivy league
it doesn't have to do this is a
priesthood of a certain kind it's a
guilt yes right yeah and
it's elite the same way Navy Seals are
Elite it's the same way the head of your
surgical team is Elite I never heard
anyone say I'm not going to allow my
child to have life-saving surgery until
we get somebody who's not who's not
elitists like give me the best effing
surgeon you can possibly find okay so
what we can't have is we can't have our
current Elite ruining the concept of
elite the elite looting party the elite
termites that are eating through this
the infrastructure every time I hear the
word I mean my simplest phrase is our
Elite are not
period that is what's true we need to
re-establish the concept of elitism
and it needs to be more like I mean you
know we brought up in the last I'm very
affected by uh Jeff Beck's passing for
some reason Jeff Beck was the most elite
of of electric guitarists
um
we're not going to Harrison Bergeron
Jeff Beck into mediocrity to serve some
goal we need an elite system and we have
to be open about it and we have to stop
lying
about you're not necessarily
underrepresented
you're only underrepresented if
you know you want it so badly you're
willing to put in 100 hour weeks you
want it so badly that you're willing to
do whatever it takes to teach yourself
this and then you're having a problem
because the color of your skin
all of us are going to stand shoulder to
shoulder to defend the people who
deserve to be here because we need to
broaden the concept of who can be elite
now with that said
I just I'm angry at you guys you have
these positions supposedly you have
tenure you let this get away from you
why is it that I'm talking about this
from outside
no someone say you have less to lose
you're not going to get your 10-year
excuse me
I have the same I have fancy degrees and
fancy post-docs just like the rest of
you and quite honestly I don't think you
guys understood the threat as early as I
did that that certainly could be true I
I think that that but you're scared and
we right because you're scared to say
it's hard to make a man trying something
he's abused our graduate student labor
program because everybody knows that
graduates China I think America admitted
America a labor force go ahead okay
you're afraid to say real things
and the truth is yes you are well well
sorry I'm afraid to say many things
right okay I'm Not Afraid in the context
okay so I'm saying nobody want I I was
at MIT in a room uh filled with Chinese
uh postdocs
and when I spoke out about the abuse of
this for Espionage and for information
gathering which is that our labor force
is our students and we don't like to
admit to it and the professors talk
about slave labor and joke about working
conditions using words like coolies
let's be honest oh science cool yeah
I've never heard that I have it on tape
slave labor on tape laughing
is reprehensible it's reprehensible but
my point is is that these Labs staff
themselves with a cryptic labor program
and certainly not all Chinese students
are spies no but China is doing exactly
what any Smart Country would do and it
is availing itself of the fact that they
are sending enormous numbers of people
into a very specialized work pipeline
and we are getting rid of the advantage
that comes from our freedom because they
can't do what we can do right it's
because they have a hierarchical system
now most of us are scared to say this
because it's a one-line argument oh
sounds like you're having a problem with
people who look different from you it's
like oh well I guess that's the argument
well just in the same case there were
quotas back uh when Feynman and others
were Jewish uh trying to get into it we
have tons of people of Chinese origin
and extraction we do and we have we have
we have Jews we have uh Indians we have
so much going for I want those people
regardless of the color of their skin or
their religious belief structure or
where they come from right right to make
use of our freedom drenched system
because I believe what it does is it
produces High variance individuals and
what we're addicted to is low variance
labor the rest of the world is much
better at low variants and we create
pains in the ass well I think this is a
symptom of what's colloquially called a
resource curse like we have in uh in
Saudi Arabia where there's this
tremendous amounts of oil and that's
allowed them to effectively bypass and
shortcut any need to develop Advanced
physics or technology Rockets Smart Ones
are figuring out how to feed themselves
away from oil right my point is the cost
saving that you imagine from moving your
supply chains to your competitors this
whole thing is based on a crazy idea
that if we just make ourselves so
interdependent no one will ever declare
war all right well that goes back to
Nixon and opening up China sure but how
is that working in Ukraine
right absolutely the old claim is is
that no no country with the McDonald's
has ever attacked another country with
the McDonald's how's that working they
don't have a McDonald's anymore
you know the other part of it is that
we've got to not focus our anger on
China China's doing the right thing by
China right we have to not focus our
anger on our Chinese students they're
doing exactly what I do most of them are
not engaged in this most of them are
just trying to immigrate right right
what we have to do is to focus on the
portion of the National Academy of
Science the National Science Foundation
that stabbed American labor in the back
uh in starting in 1986. is it more
important to rectify past injustices or
God I can't keep doing this
we screwed up and we made permanent
changes we have to undo permanent
changes stop making it into something
about vindictive it has nothing to do
I'm not saying it's vindictive I don't
think it's as relevant as you think it
is now although I am in full agreement
it was relevant in the 80s and 90s
everybody look up uh
graphs over time of the number of
foreign PhD students disaggregated by
country of origin and you tell me
whether we have a problem and see what
the slope is now see if the slope is
still the slope it's also the question
of the state it's not just the flow the
state I mean just anecdotes are not
plural of data as they say but I've
noticed far fewer I've had phenomenal
Chinese uh individuals everybody has
that have been that are now professors
in China they're not professors here
well some of them are professors here
some of them are I'm just saying
anecdotally from my personal
Laboratories and we need a certain we
serve to have we should go after they're
the best in the world right if there are
but very often we've used the best and
the brightest argument for hands I know
I never paid my Chinese graduate student
less less than I paid my American Girl
but you played your Chinese and your
American graduate students far less by
pushing out the supply curve if Supply
equals demand at a particular point I
understand okay so then you but then why
make that argument well because I think
again these are we're gonna get into
like General equilibrium versus partial
equilibrium I'm worried about refining
the piece of Refuge
we have a problem
the issue studied by the National
Science Foundation in 1986 and you can
find this on the web is is that they
schemed
to destroy the bargaining ability of
American stem workers and what they did
is that they studied supply and demand
they figured how can we get the wage
down
and then what they did is to say okay if
we release that
it's going to look terrible so what
we're going to do is we're going to
subtract off
the demand curves we're only going to
leave the supply curves we're going to
change a competent economic analysis and
we're going to turn it into an
incompetent demographic analysis we're
going to stir people up that we're not
going to have anybody to take over stem
we'll pass the Immigration Act of 1990
and then when you morons figure out what
we actually did on behalf of scientific
employers it'll all be too late and my
claim is I don't understand why can't we
revisit this Brian why are you going to
dissipate
the righteous anger whose purpose is not
vindictive
the purpose is to say we need American
Scientific employers crying for mercy
at the bargaining table
we need to have new phds being offered
250 000 in stem
look we just had a strike in the whole
University of California including my
students on strike demanding higher
above average wages and so forth their
wages of physics graduate students were
already one to two Sigma above what a
biology graduate student would earn or
chemistry graduate student would order
because we are forced by market forces
to effectively pay not but no by phys
this is in my maybe unique to
astrophysics and cosmology I don't think
it is because when I look for a postdoc
I have to advertise at the rate of a
Hubble fellow which is not an
unsubstantial amount of money what this
is is a terrible argument right the
argument is
well you know people are getting eighty
thousand dollars a year or something and
I don't know what the current yeah right
it could be for postdocs but my point is
if Wall Street
is paying way over that and the skill
set is fungible
I would like to see physicists getting
85 percent of a Wall Street salary with
a 15 premium good luck I mean me too
sorry no no good luck no Eric if my kid
here at UC San Diego if she gets into UC
San Diego or gets into Princeton or gets
into Harvard uh she will pay full
Freight if I were a Princeton Professor
or Caltech Professor if I my child gets
into UC San Diego Harvard or University
of Florida I will pay nothing for my
kids in other words there's more than
just compensation there is there are
market now I chose this because it was
the you know it was it had a lot of
advantages over other institutions
private institutions that I had a
faculty offer at for a variety of
reasons but the playing field is not
equal even at the uh
the current system because it has been
adulterated it was adulterated into the
Mansfield amendment was under in the
eilberg amendment in 1976 the buy Dole
amendment in 1980 the shortage studies
of 1986 through 90 the Immigration Act
of 1990. we are up against a series of
changes that have killed our University
system which are deliberately
because I'm the only one talking about
this Brian and so when you take the only
person talking about this well there are
in is it the University of Austin Texas
it's a new model I'm not saying uh
nobody else is willing to be a
xenophilic restrictionist because saying
you're a restrictionist is a one-line
argument oh it sounds like you don't
like people who look different Asian
hating Asia exactly so Brian so my
question is why are you playing Devil's
Advocate when you understand exactly I'm
not playing I'm saying exactly in
concert with what you're saying in the
best way is not to try to you know keep
injecting morphine into the patients be
more courageous is very clearly uh
detailed you want to look at the
Mansfield Amendment the eilberg
amendment by Dole the shortage studies
bad demography secret good economics and
the Immigration Act of 1990 among other
things and you need to repeal these
things if you want the magic back and we
also have to look at getting rid of
diversity equity and inclusion in its
simplistic form so that we can get the
diversity and inclusion that we actually
need by getting rid of the equity and
making sure that we can also exclude
people who don't deserve to be in the
room thanks today you tweeted out
um you'd like to get updates on uh the
third fourth fifth object shot down over
Alaska Yukon like here on these are
balloons or some unidentified objects
you asked about the origin of covet are
we going to get new information on eco
Health Neo NYC interference right the
origin of the source of the Epstein
trading uh Fortune paper Mass mandate
efficacy money supply changes on CPI
vaccine assessment
you get one of those no no I want to I'm
an American I want I want information
I don't want to play inside of these
nonsense Frameworks but I'm just trying
to diagnose what is key what is what one
thing I mean you're one man you're just
a man no you're just a no I have a very
large following and people follow me
because I'm willing not to be a [__]
about it we deserve all of these things
[Music]
this is normal behavior we expect to
know because we have to make a decision
every four years who's the president we
have to make a decision about senators
on a more frequent basis
and the answer is we cannot do our jobs
as an informed electorate having our
news media owned by billionaires who are
are absolutely filled with the letter of
Journalism and empty of its Spirit what
about uh Twitter where you have a large
following we will link to your Twitter
profile yes because what we know from
the Twitter uh files is that there are
government agencies that are pushing to
slow the spread of what they call Mal
information Mal information is just
information that is dangerous to a
narrative so you have steak craft where
you have to do things and then explain
what you're doing we mis-explain what
we're doing
almost every day we starve people for
information smart people say I don't get
it I don't understand and then we say
okay we need to pre-bunk
agents of Mal information in other words
we need to destroy the reputation of
non-state actors individuals citizens
who are going to spread malinformation
which is information
this is dystopia and what I'm trying to
say is we don't need Devil's advocacy
what we need is
do you not agree with me on this stuff
Brian Angels God's Advocates I I of
course I agree with you on this so we
agree I think that but I want to give
myself a little bit of an out of it no
not an out no I'm saying I am on the
ground I am I am actively in the academy
right and I am seeing things I also
think the studies that you mentioned by
the way 1986 and 1990 by I'm no
mathematician but uh those aren't you
know 2023. I I think some some things
with regard to uh low importation of
lower
um uh of of massive amounts of foreign
individuals who may be better at physics
than say an American student whatever
that means
um that is not as prevalent as it was
when those studies were written okay I'm
telling you from be encountering both
the on the as a professor I don't get a
mandate I don't have Market forces I
can't pay one student from China less
than a student from as you say the whole
thing has to go right okay so so that
but I do want to say that they're Brian
I will let you there's no out if you
understand supply curves if you
understand probably equilibrium General
equilibrium if you understand all of
this stuff this was a targeted program
to destroy us
our leaders the National Science
Foundation tried what purpose lower
wages why Eric block that would just
benefit the professors that you're
trying to subvert
I don't two things cannot be
simultaneously true they can't be doing
it for the benefit Financial or
otherwise of the ACT you have a class of
people who are in a chair those class of
people there was not going to be a new
allocation of money they were about to
see their entire pyramid structure
collapse which which structure are we
talking about all right
um this is I'm a simple man no we're
going to do mathematics for a reason
okay fine mathematics has the math
genealogy project I want everybody to go
and look up Norman steenrod at the
University of North Dakota in the math
genealogy project you'll see something
like 23 students and they all but one at
the very end in 1972 survived to
adulthood and reproduce
so if you imagine that Norman steenrod
could create a normanstein rod he would
create 23 Norman steam rods and then
you'd have 23 to higher and higher
powers and that system is going to
explode that's what was about to happen
in the early 1970s this is Derek desola
price and the workaround is to preserve
the culture and the style to which
certain professors had become accustomed
without fixing and addressing the system
okay so whoever was already in needed a
steady supply of students who would not
survive to adulthood and this became the
Hunger Games around 1973 1971 something
in there
and that structure
is lumbering forward into today which it
makes no sense what we figured out is
that we could sell visas
which have high
value but are not fungible
how how valuable is a visa to an
American citizen not at all what's more
that pushes out the supply curve so what
you did is you sold immigration
in order for one cohort to live in this
Preposterous dionysian style which is
not supportable and what needed to
happen is that there needed to be a
reckoning we probably needed to go to a
youth social education model where you
have a queen in a colony
who reproduces and most of the people
work they don't I'm sorry most of the
bees or the ants uh and hymenopter work
so what we needed is most of us not to
be fertile
and we avoided that and we avoided the
need for more money
and we avoided the need to pay Market
salaries because we were going from a
period where we were educating sub 10 of
the population of post-secondary level
to approximately 50 which was a one-time
thing
and and by the way I'm just bored of
this because I've been at this since the
early 1990s late 80s
and
academicians do not understand their
their own economics
how many graduate students have you had
not that I've graduated yeah PhD
students 15. okay
so I want you to think of yourself as a
Mormon you've had 15 graduate students
your colleagues maybe want 15 graduate
students where are these people going to
go
15 over 19 years Eric this isn't 15 at
once
you don't even have that many children
Brian
I'm working I know I know hi honey but
it's Valentine's right but what I'm
trying to get at is
at what point do I I'm trying to explain
an exponential to people who do
exponentials for a living right there's
a replacement value and then everyone
this is this is straight up Upton
Sinclair trying to explain People to
People your your idea is oh it's 15 over
19 years madness madness
I think we're gonna have to Agree to
Agree okay um
last question before we go out for our
well and sales day or celebratory
celebratory
celebrating our wives since the last
time we met Elon has taken over Twitter
yeah has that made you more optimistic
less optimistic that any of these it's
an interesting questions very valid
points are going to be answered um
there's a huge Spike right now in
anti-Semitism on Twitter
and
what you realize is that when people
start talking in terms of well
you know there's so many different
communities we have to understand
different Community norms
many of us got inured to the
issue of bigotry because of the abuse
The Crying Wolf that the woke engaged in
for five years or ten years or I don't
know where we are
those are communities
there is a Stormfront community
right 4chan Community 4chan community
and these communities are super
dangerous and we have a choice as to how
we want to constrain them
we can either do it at the level of
rules
or we can do it at the level of culture
now I'm emphatic about which I want I
want the anti-semites to have the right
to speak
and I want the the uh the anti-black
bigots and the misogynists to have the
right to speak
and I want to make that right not a
right that we see used almost at all
and in order to do that you have to have
an extremely strong culture of free
speech and that recognizes that free
speech is not the right of a society to
commit suicide
by engaging in its absolutely worst
behaviors
the problem that I see is that many
people find this entertaining oh did you
see that thing that happened oh my God
he said this and she said that and
you're thinking
do you realize how dangerous this is
that your enjoyment Your Entertainment
so
Elon has a particular belief structure
that I really dislike
which is that the most entertaining
thing is what the world will do pay
attention to and my feeling about this
is
you want to know what's entertaining
uh conspiracy theories about ethnic
groups
don't get a lot of clicks and likes
absolutely people find it interesting
they want to discuss it and
my issue is I don't want to go back on
the first amendment I want to extend the
First Amendment not only through our
society
I wanted to extend it worldwide
but people don't recognize that that
goes hand in in glove with having a
strong enough culture to resist these
things we're not interested to not use
them so I don't know what to do in a
world in which we're going to decide
that it's super entertaining
uh
you know a guy who's been very nice to
me personally is this guy Michael malis
I don't know what his real name is
but Jay Leno I think got scalded because
akara blew up on him and his face was
you know burns on his face and he
tweeted out
um
wow Leno hasn't been hot like this in
years
and I thought
wow
I I just I didn't have a
I mean I'm not necessarily a big Jay
Leno fan but that's a soul it was a
cruelty right this is yeah yeah and and
the idea is this has become normal for
us
so yay Elon getting rid of the spaghetti
code which says Elon but yay Elon well
we can talk a bit about yay too but
um
we are in a pro we are in a problem we
don't have a solution to and I used to
talk about this with Jack Dorsey and I
said I don't think that Twitter has a
solution
um it is not the case that the most
entertaining thing happening is a good
idea it's a terrible idea
you want to know it's entertaining
cruelty people love it oh yeah and one
of the things that people love about
cruelty films is that they love finding
a thin social
socially positive excuse for their
cruelty I'm not actually being cruel all
right I'm watching I'm I'm stopping a
Badness that you don't recognize you can
go on Twitter right now my my you know
child can look at a murder you can see
and during George when I'm saying
something else but something it's also
awful somebody is saying to that
um
I'm going to publish this person's
address because they are a menace to
society and the person is not a menace
to society so they come up with a
threadbare excuse because what they want
to engage in is cruelty to backfill the
narrative that allows yeah and I think
that what we have to recognize is we
seem to enjoy
cruelty and destruction as entertainment
because the phone is desensitizing us
and I you know
a lot of it came out of the
multiplayer Gaming Community where
people know that first person shooters
are not real
and so it's like ah I just splattered
your brains all over that wall Pink
missed anything right
um but then if you looked at the Christ
Church killings it looks exactly like a
first person shooter being live streamed
and my my claim is is that we've we've
blurred these distinctions so I think
that the previous Twitter was an
abomination
and I don't know how Elon is going to
try to solve this but if I had one plea
it would be
um Elon Trump and Kanye have all figured
out the drunken boxing intellectual
drunken boxing
is a good strategy for a while
because nobody knows what you're going
to do it's super entertaining but then
it goes off the rails and you know my
feeling is is that Elon is the smartest
of them and I hope
that he'll have a change of heart and
reconsideration because I actually
believe
that somewhere in him he wants the best
for the planet but I'm just going to
tell you right now is you can listen to
an entire conversation about communities
and bringing people together and you
don't realize that the KKK is a
community and there's not much of it but
that you do not want to let a few cells
replicate at an incredible rate and then
figure it out later
well we always end on a happy note here
can we I want to wish you wait wait oh
let's talk about something something
great something in science that excites
you what excites you
I'm really hoping for example that
artificial intelligence tells us
something about the um
the wiring diagram for the mind of the C
elegans nematode we have a complete
adjacency Matrix we have optogenetics
and we have green fluorescent protein
that we can attach so we can actually
watch the worm think developed here yeah
three 300 or so neurons
uh I would love it if the same
techniques that were put into protein
folding or go or chess
were put onto the worm and we found that
the machines could figure out how
thought actually occurs in a relatively
you know the simple the simplest of
systems this complex systems simplest
system that has Locomotion reproduction
and uh ingestion of food and digestion I
think that that that is a great example
of something that I think will succumb
uh before we actually have artificial
general intelligence and I really hope
that
and this is like perverse I hope we have
a near Miss
with very little casualty or loss of
life in Ukraine and everyone sits bolt
upright and said oh my God this is not
safe to be on this planet what do we do
now what we need
is to Galvanize a Manhattan Project to
allow non-scientific people and
scientific people alike to decide
whether they want to stay here with G
Putin Biden Trump uh yeah Trump nasrola
uh coming because I don't want to be
anywhere near any of these people I will
take my chances in the cosmos not all of
these experiments can work but this
thing is about to go critical and I
don't know whether it's going to be 50
years 150 years or five years
but um I'm really hoping that what we
see is a Renaissance in terms of
technically capable people shouldering
the responsibility
of recognizing that we're waiting for
the bread to rise and that this place is
a womb and it's time to be born we
started the you know pitocin uh in
1952-53 and uh it's now time to go
fitting for February 14th which is the
date in which Carl Sagan commanded the
Voyager 1 spacecraft the farthest object
made by mankind sent
back in the early
1970s to do a grand tour of the universe
and on that fateful day in 1990 on
Valentine's Day exactly a 33 years ago
he commanded it to point out the Earth
and called it the famous pale blue dot
do you remember the uh it was just when
he was beyond the orbit of Uranus and do
you remember the story about the golden
record
the story Eric I had on the subject of
the golden record who I'd love to have
you a host on the portal God willing you
will inshallah initiate it again
andrewian well as a guest years ago I
remember Saturday night Live's Weekend
Update saying that we sent this record
with all of these different uh you know
Bantu uh haulers and calls World music
The Box B minor Mast and Chuck Berry and
that we got a faint Echo from the
farthest reaches of space which said
send more Chuck Berry
uh on that happy note
thank you my friend thank you it's great
to see you great to be in person stay
tuned for more great episodes if you'd
like to see an episode where Eric
outlines what he would do if he ran
Weinstein University go to the back
catalog we'll put a link in somewhere
for you to find uh our most uh frequent
and requested guests thank you so much
for joining us on the into the
impossible book
foreign
[Music]